joining us now Democrat Congressman
Henry Clay are also from Texas closer to
the Border there welcome back to Fox
News Sunday sir
thank you and good morning to you I want
to get your thoughts as well on the
shooting yesterday in Texas following
just quickly on the heels of one a
little bit more than a week ago
um Uvalde so many of these you know
Church shootings and others that come to
mind Where Do We Go From Here when
people don't feel safe at malls at
churches at schools or at home
yes and and first of all to uh you know
to the families our thoughts our prayers
that hopefully they'll be able to heal
second of all we need to find out
answers exactly what happened here uh
and again we we need to find out there's
always a reason why certain people and
there's always there's always telltale
signs before you there's indicators that
we can should have looked at for but
again uh to the law enforcement that put
a stop to this you know again I thank
them and we've seen this in Uvalde we
saw that in my in my district Sutherland
spring some time ago at a church uh and
it's one of those things that we need to
look at and again it's making sure we
get at the root problems and and I do
agree with the governor you know mental
health is one of the things that's why
at the federal level we've added
billions of dollars for mental health
and if people talk about just you know
making the law stricter uh you got to
look at you know in in states or blue
very strict laws you still get this type
of mass shoot it so it does happen
Across the Nation and we have to get to
the bottom of this absolutely you are
here to talk about the about them as
well so let's talk about what we heard
from secretary Marcus says the border is
closed it's not going to open after
title 42 lifts this week you heard the
governor say that's absolutely not true
here's what the border patrol Union
tweeted out don't believe anything the
White House says the last 10 days 7 700
arrests per day title 42 hasn't ended
yet and it's going to get worse 700
percent increase over normal day during
Obama and Trump administrations we have
lying propagandists running this country
in DHS right now who is telling the
truth congressman
you know surely we're seeing people
coming in the borders uh open there are
some policies that in my opinion should
have been implemented some years ago uh
we need to have a very simple thing at
the border repercussions that is people
that are supposed to stay here uh should
be able to stay under the law and if
they have to be returned they have to be
returned quickly you got to have some
repercussions because if you don't have
repercussions at the border people are
going to see the Border as a speed bump
and they'll be coming in at this time so
we got to have repercussions at the
border and remember I know a lot of
times they say well the immigration
system is broken the immigration system
is broken yes we do need to have
immigration reform but keep in mind
President Obama uh you know for the
folks that we're not supposed to be here
actually deported more people than
president Trump so there's a way that
you can have Law and Order at the border
and still respect the legitimate I
emphasize the word legitimate women
Asylum claims I want to read something
from one of the president's rare
Democratic Challengers this is RFK Jr
who says we have to think about what's
drawing the people here in a tweet
earlier this week he said in part he
said in large part it is U.S policies
that create desperate conditions South
of the Border he went on to add it is
inhumane and hypocritical to deny
immigration while creating the
conditions that drive in Immigration
that's what critics say this
Administration is doing though creating
the magnets creating the conditions what
do you say
what look there are pull factors and
push factors push factors of course are
certain conditions all across the world
in the old days it was Mexican single
male adults who would come in to come
work then in the 2000s you had Central
American countries uh and then lately
you've had people from Venezuela
Nicaragua Cuba that know that the U.S
doesn't have a good working relationship
with that country and it's hard to send
those people back uh and then of course
uh lately at the border you have over 60
countries that are represented it's
almost like a many U.N down there
because there are so many people named
the Africa uh you know the Middle East
uh China Vietnam they're coming in
because again there are push factors in
those countries but there's also pull
factors and the pull factors is what I
said at the beginning if you don't have
consequences at the border it doesn't
matter what you do they're going to keep
coming well the numbers are
exponentially higher under the this
Administration I mean that's just hard
data so what are your conversations with
the White House like about the fact that
people think no matter what officials
say the border is open and millions of
them have showed up in the last couple
of years those are just the ones we know
about
you know and if you look at at the last
two years yes you've had over 4.3
million individuals that have been
encountered by border patrol uh that
doesn't even include the getaways uh so
far as of Friday we had about a two
percent increase at the same time we've
had over I think it's about uh one point
uh 1.2 uh million individuals so far in
the fiscal year still not over so people
are coming in and again I go back you
got to make that decision at the border
because if you don't make that decision
at the border they're going to come in
either taxpayers dollars like Governor
Abbott is doing or or they're going to
be flying in or going through other
buses they're going to come into the
interior and once they come into the
interior and and let me talk about New
York there's about 10 cities where most
of this migrants are going New York is
number one and and when they give those
notice to report that is to ice not
before an Immigration Court in New York
City it's going to be told 20
the legal way I want to put something up
this is another recent Fox News poll we
have just out on how the president is
doing on any number of issues on the
issue of immigration 36 percent approve
of how he's doing 61 disapproved that is
a two to one margin the White House is
blaming Congress they say you guys are
not getting the job done on reforming
this issue but how much blame do you
think the White House Bears because the
American people seem to think the
president has a big problem on his hands
look let me put it this way President
Obama did not have a immigration reform
he pushed for DACA in which I support
and I support uh I support full
immigration reform but there were no
changes in the laws or under President
Obama he was able to use title eight in
which is a kernel instead of title 42
and he was able to treat people with
respect but if they had to be returned
he sent them back he had images of
airplanes going back right now the only
image that we see is people coming in no
images of people going back so yes the
American public is frustrated now the
administration needs to go to the center
and I've asked them to go to the center
and I think some of the policies that
they're about to implement brings him to
the center in my opinion a little bit
too late but at least they're getting
policies that will come to the center do
they take your calls
I haven't called the White House I call
I talked to secretary mayorka Trey
Miller Troy Miller and other folks at
border patrol Chiefs at the border I go
directly to Homeland because a lot of
them are career people and we got to
make sure that the career people have a
have a say-so at the table and again
it's okay to listen to immigration
activists but you got to listen to the
men and women in Green in Blue from uh
Homeland and you certainly have to
listen to The Border communities like
Laredo Texas because we're taking the
brunt of what's Happening down here at
the border yeah that is the reality and
God bless those men and women in uniform
doing their absolute best there
Congressman thank you good to see you
again
thank you Sean it's a pleasure I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis